Now to Ukraine, where the
military says
it has inflicted huge
losses on Russian forces near
the embattled eastern city,
that it's been seeing fierce
fighting for months now.
Meanwhile, Kremlin backed officials
in this Upper East
region are evacuating civilians
living in occupied towns.
That includes the area
around the nuclear power station.
Ukrainian workers at the plant
are not being allowed to leave,
though their family members
are being evacuated.
CNN's Nick Paton Walsh is in Zyprexa
and joins me now live
What are we hearing about that
then in the situation there?
Yeah, it is extraordinary.
Seems reversal
against Russia
here, a
significant part of the front line
apparently given up
by conventional Russian troops
who are seen on some footage
put out by Ukrainian officials
fleeing the area.
Now, this was first brought to light,
indeed, by Russia itself.
Russia's mercenary had Yevgeny
Prigozhin talking about how he'd lost 500
of his fighters holding
and taking this particular area.
But it was the conventional
Russian military
that appeared to have fled.
That was then confirmed
by Ukrainian military
figures as well, who claimed
and you know,
it's always hard to put too much stock
into casualty numbers in this conflict.
But claim that 200 have been killed
and 200 have been injured
as Russia gave those positions up.
But remember,
this is a stark change
in the narrative here.
A few weeks ago,
Russian forces were talking
about the possibility
they might be able to encircle
the remaining
Ukrainian holdout forces in the city,
cutting off some of the lost roads.
Then we had this extraordinary
public spat.
Yevgeny Prigozhin demanding
more artillery shells,
pointing the finger squarely
at the Russian defense ministry
for not providing
adequate resources for him.
He threatened to leave today.
Yesterday, he said he hadn't,
in fact, even received
those artillery shells.
And now today, he's suggesting that
the Russian conventional military
has abandoned some positions
that his men had fought and lost for. So.
A startling
display of public disunity, frankly,
from the Russians here.
He's consistent
in his criticism vocal, frankly, almost,
and in a way unheard of in Putin's Russia
against the top brass
of the Russian military
and Ukraine clearly
seeking to capitalize upon this.
It isn't clear
if this marks the beginning of a broader
Russian route
around that city of parliament.
Ukrainian officials are saying
it's not actually artillery shells
that Russia appears to be short of.
They're saying the barrage continues
as it always has done,
but in fact,
running out of people on the ground.
So certainly
a testing moment around parliament.
It's been the singular
objective of Russia
by far and its conventional military over
all the winter.
They said they take it by yesterday.
They just simply haven't managed
to achieve this one. Compare actively.
Simple task.
Despite
throwing thousands of men at a city
which is strategically
not that significant
for Russia's broader goals here.
So remarkable,
frankly, that we're hearing this disunity
and this reverse
from Russia here
and its fortunes on the front line Max.
Okay. Nick Paton Walsh is appreciate.
Thank you.
Now, it seems for some
Ukrainians,
the war has become almost background
noise to their daily lives.
And whilst
every day brings
the very real risk of being killed
after 14 months of conflict,
it seems many are almost numb to it all.
CNN's Nic
Robertson reports
now from eastern Ukraine.
Already
a few miles from Ukraine's eastern front.
Life is, well, sort of normal,
although it's not outside of war.
Who needs this much callow kid
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
You gave me a nice wooly
hat to keep me warm.
I've seen people friendly,
not frozen in fear,
even though they feel it right.
We don't know what's happening.
30 minutes from now,
she says, let alone an hour
No worries.
Shown in the town park, either.
Workers trimmed the grass as artillery
shells tear up not so distant fields.
Showing fear,
it seems, is an abandoned indulgence.
Air raid warnings passé now
the sirens have become such a background
part of people's lives
here, living through the war.
They don't even respond.
Take notice, flinch, even War is just
as a present.
The faded through people's lives
outside of town.
Even closer to the front,
this elderly couple nonchalantly
tell us their home was shelled
last month.
He even jokes.
It's boring when there's no shooting.
Both, though, hopeful Ukraine's coming
counter-offensive
will end their suffering
But we believe Ukraine will go in there
and beat the well.
His wife says
further on, pensioners in Novi
is more worried
about his weeds than the war ruins
We don't understand anything
about the counteroffensive, he says.
We just hope for our Ukraine,
for our defense.
Where and when the
counteroffensive may begin.
It's one of the war's
best kept secrets so far.
The mystery
is exactly what Ukraine wants.
Keep Russia guessing.
Stretch their supply lines.
SAP troop morale.
Ukraine's victory rides on surprise
Driving around near the front lines
here,
you can hear some shelling
in the distance.
And you can see
plenty of soldiers around.
But what you don't get a sense of
is any big buildup
for a counteroffensive.
Farmers
here are counting on their troop success
sowing crops in fields
they want to harvest in full.
The other one of the Mikkeller hopes
the counter offensive
will secure his land,
but says he knows some of the soldiers
around here
knows how hard the fight will be.
Knows it will be a bloody battle.
Nic Robertson, CNN, eastern Ukraine.
Clare, this lack of grain
leaving the ports
in Ukraine, effectively,
that green deal appears to be dead
right now.
It's on the brink.
It expires in eight days
time on May 18th.
Russia
only extended it in March for 60 days,
even though when it was agreed
back in July last year.
The agreement
was that every time it was extended,
it would be for 120 days.
They're now saying the U.N.
has said that on Sunday and Monday
there were no inspections of ships.
They've now restarted inspections
on outbound ships and leaving
Ukrainian ports
for the global markets
through those sort of maritime corridors.
That were agreed.
But, you know,
Russia is making this hard.
There were expert
level talks last week
that did not end well.
They're now moving to senior level talks.
They expected to start today
in Istanbul with deputy foreign ministers
from the U.N.
from from sorry,
from Ukraine, from Russia
and Turkey and U.N.
representatives as well
to try to revive this deal
I think the problem
the problem for Russia
is that they're saying that
a separate agreement
that was agreed last July,
which was supposed to help
smooth the path
for their food
and fertilizer, export exports
to global markets is not being met.
They're saying sanctions
is getting in the way.
Clearly,
they're looking to have
some of those sanctions lifted.
But I think, you know,
this is also Russia at a time
when it's clearly on the back foot
on the battlefield,
struggling to
defend as well as attack
is trying to show Ukraine
and the world
that this is one area
where it still has a treacherous course,
but subfreezing
Huge amount of concern
about the nuclear plant there
because people
are being evacuated from the area.
Yeah.
So they're evacuating the families
of the staff
of the nuclear plant from an affidavit
it is the town that's adjacent
to the
sort of like a
feeder town into that plant.
But we're now hearing this morning
that they're not allowing
the actual Ukrainian staff to leave.
Now, we know that
a number of Ukrainian staff
have remained in the plant
throughout this conflict.
The plant has been occupied by Russia
really since the first weeks of the war.
They need them there to keep running it.
Russia does not have people.
They can just bring in
just like that
to keep running this plant.
So that's, I think, what's going on here.
But it is extremely nerve wracking.
We know that this plant is vulnerable.
We know there's weapons on the site.
Certainly according to the Ukrainians.
But I think the most important thing
here is what we don't know.
We just don't have a lot of visibility
about what
Russia has been doing
there, how they've been running it,
the amount of military equipment there.
And that's certainly
what's been worrying the Ukrainian side.
Okay, Claire,
thank you very much indeed, also, Nic.